very bad feeling about bad feeling about
this
I don't know I have a bad feeling about
hey everybody hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie this is gonna be
my easter egg and references video so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet we'll be talking about the cameos
all the things that they included from
the previous films there were a lot of
things in the story as well as things
the characters did said or walked around
with that reference moments from
previous films were at the 8th film in
the saga so of course there's gonna be a
lot of things in the story that directly
reference stuff or parody it from
earlier in the series so if you're just
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll still
keep doing the imax to get give away for
the next couple of weeks - starting with
the celebrity cameos first you may have
heard Joseph gordon-levitt but you
probably didn't recognize him when you
spotted him he was playing a character
called slow lean low the little tiny
person that ratted out Finan rose on
kanto bite in the casino scenes the
codebreaker that they had been sent to
find wearing that rose on his jacket was
actually played by justin theroux
remember they got thrown in prison
before they were able to find him and
they had to go with their backup choice
Benicio del Toro Prince Harry and Prince
William were in the movie playing two
different stormtroopers with their
helmets on so you wouldn't have
recognized them ellie goulding was in
the movie she was a resistance pilot but
her cameo was cut there were actually a
couple of celebrity cameos that were cut
from the film so you didn't see
everybody Tom Hardy was another example
of that greg grunberg snap Wexley
character from force awakens came back
he was early in the film just a very
brief appearance on screen Gary Fisher
was space Gary he was actually dressed
up like an alien in the kanto bite
scenes there were actually several
people in that casino scene dressed up
as aliens so you wouldn't have
recognized them Warwick Davis was this
tall flat nosed alien so he was mostly
lending his voice another one of the
actors that shows up in all of Rian
Johnson's films is Noah seekin you may
have spotted him as a resistance pilot
that was boarding a plane earlier in the
film Edgar Wright and Joe Cornish both
had cameos on the Radice that early Mon
Calamari Cruiser there were a couple
more notable voices
in the film from celebrity guest stars
that we don't know exactly who they were
playing we just know that they were in
the film michael giacchino whos the
composer played a voice Matthew wood the
voice of General Grievous voiced
somebody in the film then Sam Witwer
who's done a bunch of different Star
Wars stuff was a voice of a character
who we don't know who he was but he was
the voice of Darth Maul during clone
wars during Star Wars rebels he was also
in the Force Unleashed he's done a bunch
of Star Wars you may have heard about
Gareth Edwards and Rian Johnson both
letting each other cameo in the others
film so during rogue one Rian Johnson is
one of the people firing the Death Star
laser when they're activating it so he
has that big Gunners helmet on it you
can't tell that it's him but you can
clearly see Gareth Edwards face as all
the resistance people are climbing into
the trenches on crate preparing for the
first-order assault the actress that
plays AI Denver CO in the battlefront 2
series Janina gavankar was right next to
nian dub when they were on the
resistance ship early in the film but
probably the funniest cameo is actually
by Mark Hamill himself so Mark Hamill
obviously Luke Skywalker is a huge part
of the story of the film but he also
starred as another role so he gave his
voice to one of the creatures on Kanto
bite he's only credited as da Bousquet
so he might be that little creature
that's trying to throw coins into bb-8
like a slot machine but Mark Hamill was
a notable voice actor so it makes sense
that they would try to use his voice but
it is sort of a funny cameo given that
he plays such a big role as his normal
character Luke Skywalker in the film one
of the most cry worthy references was
when r2d2 played Leia's original message
to obi-wan for Luke cheap-shot buddy
sacred planet watch your language so
r2d2 just as foul-mouthed as ever but
when they were using moments like that
in the film they also reused a lot of
old theme songs from earlier films they
played Han and Leia's theme when they
were referencing Leia kylo Ren scenes
Luke's themed the theme of the force
when he was watching the twin sons
before he ascended to the force which is
also a direct reference during a new
hope where he walks out and looks out to
the horizon seeing the twin suns of
Tatooine so there were a lot of music
Easter egg and references to previous
films like in snoke's throne-room they
played the emperor's theme from Return
of the Jedi when he started to torture
Rea most of the stuff that happened on
October n'stuff that Yoda did on Dagobah
during Empire Strikes Back in Return of
the Jedi so even though it's the middle
film and a lot of people said that there
were a lot of references and moments
from Empire Strikes Back he was really a
combination of Empire Strikes Back in
Return of the Jedi because not only does
Rey go seeking a master out to get his
help but he also then dies at the end of
that kylo Ren killing Snoke is also a
mirror for Darth Vader killing the
Emperor so there was a lot of Return of
the Jedi in the film but the cave scene
was one of the biggest ones so both ray
and Luke go into their respective caves
the Dagobah cave or the Ock - cave
seeking answers about their identity the
cave shows Luke who he is he is Vader he
could become Vader it's a potential
future for him but a lot of people were
confused about what Rey saw she just saw
near-infinite different variations of
herself
then later when kylo Ren tells her
you're no one you've always known your
parents sold you for drinking money
there were a lot of people that thought
that he was being dishonest trying to
mislead her but the director confirmed
that what was happening in that moment
is is that because their minds were
connected kylo Ren was able to see what
she saw in the cave so he believed that
he was telling her the truth from his
point of view you know they say a
certain point of view that's a big theme
in Star Wars but in the most [ __ ] way
possible because kylo Ren is kind of an
[ __ ] most people in my theater
laughed when they did the blue milk
Easter Egg when Luke milks that giant
creature they'll probably have to find
some other way to do blue milk in the
next film when Luke says he cut himself
off from the force you actually learned
during the Darth Vader comic by Charles
Hsu that is called the beresch vow it's
a sort of penance that Jedi take on
themselves so there is a technical term
for it there were a lot of you that
noticed way back when the first trailer
dropped a long time ago that when Luke
extends his metal hand out to take his
father's lightsaber there's still a
blaster score mark on it from when it
was hit on Jabba's Sail Barge back
during Empire Strikes Back but you also
may have spotted Luke's compass from
battlefront to
that showed up during the film there's a
moment during battlefront too when
you're in one of the emperor's secret
vaults Luke shows up he finds a compass
that shows up during the film there were
a lot of people that were confused about
how the books from the Jedi Tree made it
all the way to the Falcon because you
see them as Finn is covering up rose he
opens the drawer and all the Jedi texts
are there that you saw inside the tree
so presumably at some point Reis stole
them
Yoda knew this so when he burned down
the tree he was cackling with delight
while Luke was freaking out he says very
specifically the girl already possesses
everything within those books that's
because he literally knows she has the
books themselves which also probably
contain instructions for constructing
new lightsabers because she has the
broken pieces of Anakin Skywalker's
lightsaber so I think we can all agree
that there is going to be a rematch
between kylo Ren and Rey but she's going
to have to fix that lightsaber before
she can fight him again one of the most
notable changes that they made was
turning Yoda back into a puppet so they
made him a creature rather than do him
with CG like they did during the
prequels they actually had to campaign
for that although technically he was a
puppet during Phantom Menace while he
does offer a lot of new wisdom about how
kylo Ren and Rey are going to grow
beyond what Luke and Yoda were we are
what they grow beyond that's the burden
of all masters he also directly
references a lot of the things that he
said to Luke when they were back on
Dagobah always looking to the future not
to the here and now as he bops him on
the head with a cane the same way he was
bopping r2d2 not to be forgotten though
there was one very notable darth sidious
shout out when luke skywalker talked
about the plot of the prequels the jedi
order failed they allowed darth sidious
to rise and strike them down there
weren't a whole lot of Snoke Easter eggs
aside from the Emperor's throne room but
there was a lot of Jodorowsky's dune the
Praetorian guards were obviously visual
references for the Emperor's red
stormtrooper guard but also Andy Serkis
confirmed that the gold flowing robes
that Snoke wore were based on Hugh
Hefner's wardrobe so they said that you
look when they were envisioning the
character they're like we can
make him look like whatever we want he
can wear whatever wardrobe we want who
do we want a reference and they're like
we want to go for opulence the picture
of someone who loves the trappings of
wealth in excess that would be Hugh
Hefner the perfect example of that
probably one of the biggest ones I've
seen people bummed out about though is
the fact that nobody said I have a bad
feeling about this but the director
confirmed that someone said it it just
wasn't a human that said it it was bb8
at the very beginning when Poe is making
his first run at the dread-nots so he
says it but he says it in beat form so
people just don't detect it there was
also the twist on the you rebel scum
line from the original trilogy that they
gave to the Finn character when he was
fighting phasma there are obviously a
billion Easter eggs it's the longest
Star Wars film of any film it's two and
a half hours long so it's probably gonna
take three or four more times watching
it to catch everything but if you did
spotted anything big that I didn't
mention in the video just write it below
in the comments so what will happen is
is one of my next videos in the next
couple of days will be for episode 9 and
all the hanging plot threads the JJ
Abrams is going to have to address
because just the last day is I'm posting
this video he pitched the story of
episode 9 to Disney CEO Bob Iger so
presumably they're gonna make some
changes about how to deal with the Leia
character they're probably going to
address her passing away in the opening
crawl but we can talk about that when I
post my episode 9 predictions video so
there is a new round of that IMAX 2
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Star Wars on the video I'll
announce a new winner when I post that
you can click here to learn about all
the new force powers in the changes to
Jedi lore in the film and click here for
my top 10 WTF questions after the end of
the film thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight